[Music]
dr lindbergh and i were both
uh on the board of directors of scampc
the symposium computer applications in
medical care
he says well i got this great idea he
says i think that
we ought to have computer-based medical
education in the medical schools
which sounds like like so what's new
but in 86 this was revolutionary he says
and in order to set up
to do that i have to make set up a new
branch
i was offered the position and that was
the educational technology branch
what i did as as the branch chief was go
around the country
to whoever would listen and give talks
about how you could use
video discs in those days and computers
for medical education
and that was right around the time that
the library came out with a pathology
video disc
so i had a disc with information on it
and you could write programs that would
access the disk and
create your own pathology course so i
had a the basis for giving a talk
i gave the talk a lot of places when i
gave it at the university of washington
the chairman of the biological structure
department they didn't call it anatomy
they called biological structure
said to me if you want to teach use
computers for teaching
in a medical school you should use it
for the teaching of anatomy
and i said well why and he said because
anatomy is three-dimensional
you the group gets to take it apart once
from one direction
not three-dimensionally if that group
does it wrong they don't get to see what
we want them to see hopefully the group
next will do it and they can look over
their shoulders he said if we could do
it on a computer
then we could do it over and over again
you could take it home for homework you
do
like like studying math you could study
it
and from every direction so i took the
light the
the uh the idea back to the library
uh dan macy's was the director of lister
hill he was very supportive
and he explained that i had to go see
axe gorman
and hack was the director of research
and education and hack said
well you have to have a reason to do
this it has to be in the long range plan
oh don't worry
it's in the long-range plan he says it's
in the fourth little book
and he got it out and he
he showed me the lines which said that
the nlm should
study the use of digital image libraries
he says so what you're telling me is you
want to create an anatomical
digital image library dan macy's and i
call a meeting of the people from the
anatomy departments that i discovered
and what they said was the library
should provide
the anatomical images the digital images
of the entire body one body so
everything would meet
and give it to them and let them worry
about the education
so the visible human project was born
would the visible project have happened
without lister hill i don't think so
i think the lister hill center brought
the right
things together it would have happened
at a university if the universities
could have found enough money it might
have happened in industry
we checked it but it didn't fit the
business plan and
they weren't sure and so on so
it had to happen in the way i look at
things in government
where does technology meet clinical
medicine
if not the lister hill center
you